[Music]
china's economy has developed at an
extraordinary rate
in europe and the us the mood has been
shifting
sharply and quickly china is so huge
that it comprises different realities at
the same
time the global economy itself is
starting to somewhat fragment
china's economy has developed at an
extraordinary rate over the last 40
years
across so many areas the size of its
domestic market
the technical prowess of its leading
companies
even the feats of exploration in space
and its growing military might have
astounded the rest of the world
but martin the key question now is
will china become the center of the
global economy
there is no doubt that china's growth up
to
this point and its continuing growth
mean
that it will be a major player
in the global economy forever more but
there are reasons to doubt that it will
be the center the unique
center of a global economy partly
because
other parts of the world will not be
keen to let it and partly because the
global economy itself
is starting to somewhat fragment into a
more regionalized
rather than a globalized economy
i went to china as a student nearly 40
years ago
and it was a place completely different
from the high-tech
economic superpower that we see today
there was rationing of grain
cotton and several other basic
commodities and a train from hong kong
to beijing
took over four days to arrive the same
journey today would take about nine
hours
the best statistic i think to put this
extraordinary
change into context is average gdp
growth
and since 1979 to the end of 2018
china's gdp growth averaged 9.5 percent
a year martin is this unique
as far as you know in in history
well i think it is unique in the
following sense there have been other
countries that have racked up
higher growth rates for a little bit of
time but you've never seen anything
of this size go back 2 000 years
when everyone was equally poor the point
of gravity the center of gravity of the
global economy basically followed
population
size and then with the renaissance and
the industrial revolution
you saw europe and then later north
america forge ahead
in the last 40 years it's been moving
back towards
towards asia into asia and towards china
but in a sense it's really just getting
back to what
used to be the normal state
still kind of extraordinary that they've
done it so fast even if it's a return to
normality as i call it
but james how did they do it
to start with in the late 70s they began
a program of
market reforms that really overhauled
the entire
uh communist command economy by the
early to mid 90s
they began to really put an accent on
attracting foreign direct investment but
i think the really
key change in china came again probably
in the mid 90s when china began to allow
the sons and daughters of farmers to
migrate
from the village to these big factory
towns
i would say that the chinese communist
party has sort of proved that capitalism
works
capitalism and freeing up the movement
of labor
but let me add one other aspect of this
which is how
the western high-income countries were
pursuing globalization at the time
because in the 80s and the 90s you saw
a big push for more liberalized global
trade
so globalization was taking place at the
behest and led by
the high-income countries but china
could just slot
straight into that a big part of the
answer to the question we're asking
whether china will become the center of
the global economy
is whether that development model can
continue
to work because what strikes me is that
with all of this success
china is still a relatively poor country
isn't that right
absolutely in fact china currently ranks
61st in the world in terms of
countries by their average per capita
incomes on an aggregate basis
china is still very much a developing
nation
but it's a very anomalous country as
well because
it's got all of this high-tech prowess
it's got this amazing infrastructure
it's a very different type of economic
beast i think from
the type of developed country that we
can see elsewhere in the world
[Music]
let's look at chinese average income
compared to
the world leader the u.s and we can see
that
while it was very poor before this whole
economic revolution happened it's still
not rich
china is so huge that it comprises
different realities at the same time the
chinese middle class
numbers these days about 400 million
people
that is obviously greater than the
entire population of the united states
but there's also about a billion chinese
that are much
less well off economies call this the
middle income trap you get to a certain
point
fast growth and then you kind of
stagnate
before you've pulled everyone into the
middle class
i mean one reason why people think that
happens is because
getting from poor to middle income it's
a very different process from getting to
middle income to
high income chinese consumers last year
spent
about 7.3 trillion us dollars
that by the way is greater than the
entire gdp of the japanese economy
but now i think we're entering a very
different phase and that one
is characterized by chinese emergence as
a technological power
i think that's crucial james because one
thing that economics and economic
history show
is that if there's a way out of the
middle income trap it's by
changing from a growth model based on
accumulating labor and capital
to a growth model led by technological
development and technological progress
[Music]
china is likely to be and really already
is
a middle-income country that leads the
world
in many areas of technology let me just
put some flesh on those bones
let's just count the sectors in which
china is either a global leader or at
least close to the cutting edge
a wind and solar power online payment
systems
digital currencies aspects of artificial
intelligence such as facial recognition
quantum computing satellites and space
exploration
5g telecoms drones ultra high voltage
power transmission china really is
kind of at the cutting edge of a lot of
important technologies in the world
so maybe i can ask you james if you
agree that there's a very conscious
strategy here among chinese policymakers
to to make the world more sinocentric
china's driving its uh standards
setting processes around the world
precisely to do as you
describe to try to
ensure that the latest technologies
around the world are at least
partly or largely dependent on chinese
technologies
it looks to me like the intention is
there to be
the unique global center the big
question though
is whether the rest of the world is
going to play ball and let that happen
[Music]
it's not often fully appreciated that
the globalization we've seen in the last
few decades
it's still quite regionally organized
in this chart that looks looks at
different economies
weight in the global trading system and
the main trading relationship
what we really see is three hubs one
centered on germany one centred on china
one centered on the us
and if we look at the more complex kind
of trade relationships
global value chains where inputs cross
borders many times
it looks even more regional so
i think that this is actually the
direction we're going
that we're probably going to see even
more intensification of trade
relationships
at regional level but not necessarily
that much more deep trade or deepening
of trade happening between the three big
blocks the eu the u.s
and china it's certainly true that china
is putting a
big accent on expanding its trade and
investment relationship with
southeast asia which i think it
increasingly sees
as a backyard market as it were also
china would be very reluctant to
in any way give up uh its u.s market
or the european market i mean these are
huge drivers of
china's export growth so we'll see what
sort of choice
china is given about this because it's
very clear that
in europe and the us the mood has been
shifting
sharply and quickly and i think the fact
that global trade
in itself is moving to more towards more
complex
value chains and more services trade and
digital trade
that also is going to strengthen the
political aversion to integrating with
with china so this is why i think that
while china will
as i said forevermore be a major part of
the global economy
we are probably looking more at regional
dominance
than becoming the unique center of one
homogenous global economy i think the
scenario that the world
splits into three or more regional
trading blocks
is certainly not conventional wisdom at
the moment
and if the world was to move into that
direction it would suffer
huge disruptions there would be
protectionism
the decoupling of supply chains and
several other reversals as well
however sitting here in hong kong i can
see the pressures that might lead to
such an
outcome building up so i think the key
point right now is that unless the eu
the us and china can sort out their
differences
we could see the regionalization of
global trade
becoming a reality in several years time